hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played in London 1922
on the wide end capablanca and he's
playing against a player whose name is
easier shown than said
okay
Kappa probably the main player who has
had the greatest impression on my own
game
fantastic positional understanding
in this game we're gonna see out of this
Queen's Gambit declined many weaknesses
created on Black's Queen side
and white is really quick to pounce on
those weaknesses this is a 38 move game
but by move 20 in a completely balanced
material State the game is essentially
over
so let's see how white is able to obtain
this strategically one position so
quickly
I believe it begins right about here
White's decision on move seven move
eight
are not necessarily provoking weaknesses
how to describe them they are first and
foremost sensible moves
that give black an opportunity to create
a weakness in his own camp
alright white begins with Rook C1 there
is a lag on moves seven and eight with
the light Square Bishop
white would like to see black initiate
the capture on C4 that way he could
recapture in one go
black doesn't fight in comes C6
strengthening D5 a hole is created on D6
but this isn't really a point white can
take advantage of all right in comes
Queen C2
so the minor excuse me the major pieces
are being deployed here on move seven
and eight while that's going on this
tension Still Remains
between C4 and D5 now if white releases
the tension let's say in this move eight
black would be taking with the E Pawn so
that this guy is happy
a door has opened for the bishop there's
no longer a pawn there would no longer
be upon an E6
Queen C2 though
Where Do We Go From Here considered one
of the better ideas for black here
is to play H6 get in a flight square and
then make a similar move on the queen
side with A6
this baby-like move is next looking to
initiate the capture on C4 whether or
not this guy has moved and then continue
with B5 Bishop B7 and next shoot for C5
alright in this game though black looks
at it like this
you know what I can't wait for you to
capture on D5 so that I could recapture
and then open this door there's no
guarantee this door will open for me I
have three minor pieces out let's work
on the fourth in comes B6
a door has opened for black at the same
time a weakness has been created on C6
so these guys their eyes now light up to
the C6 Square
how did we get here we're only eight
Moves In
what was maybe the main contributor to
this first weakness on the C6 Square
I would say Patience by white patience
with developing the light Square Bishop
patience with this tension not being so
quick to release it
okay only after this door has opened for
the bishop does white say fine I got a
little something you created a hole on
C6 now I'll release the tension and open
up this second door for your Bishop
okay light Square Bishops out and about
castles flight Square for black black
goes with
this idea to exchange dark Square
Bishops this isn't considered
a best idea but it is playable let's say
there you go the dark Square Bishops
white is now hinting at a central break
anticipates that goes with Queen to d8
this is considered one of the better
moves in the position
if black is not
getting the Queen off of the E file
there is some
uncomfortable situation after let's say
Rook to E8 and E4
possible night jumps maybe even getting
into D6
it likes this position for white already
ideas of focusing on F7 as well
okay in this game Queen d8 straight away
so now if E4 is played Black could take
and then immediately challenge this guy
without fear of the night jump into D6
in this game though what does white play
white plays on The Queen side
keeps the central structure as is
Queen A4
so what's the idea by white
how would you react as black in this
position
feel free to pause the video
okay
now
one of the ideas that crossed my mind
when I saw Queen to A4 is
oh white is looking to exchange light
Square Bishops White's looking to play
Bishop to A6
now this may be a bit counter-intuitive
especially if you're familiar with good
and bad Bishops this is the good Bishop
this is the bad Bishop why would white
want to pursue such an exchange well if
there are no light Square Bishops on
board
that's where we could see the weakness
on C6 it becomes more prominent
so this is
possibly an idea for white
Black's move here
is A6 stopping the exchange of light
Square Bishops however
this move do know is not yet an idea for
white it is tactically flawed
what's considered a good move consider
one of the better moves here Rook to the
half open file
what is the flaw exactly if white reacts
to this move with Bishop A6
B5 would hit
where does the queen go she has to still
move and stay defending the bishop well
after Queen A3 now in comes B4 and next
Black will win either the bishop or the
Knight
so it's nearby there's still a little
bit more work before this is actually an
idea
for instance after Rook E8 white could
consider first queen A3 and now this is
some idea
okay
in this game though A6 straight away
and now with A6 there's what a new
weakness created on the queen side
B6 is now a whole
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video can you spot what capablanca's
next move is
okay
he goes with Bishop to F5
what's the idea well let me first throw
another pop quiz your way
how would you improve here as black how
would you
continue to develop your side of the
board
feel free to pause the video
okay considered the best move here as
black is to develop the Knight
I'm drawing some attention to that
particular term
to develop the night I mean to bring
this Knight that's on the edge
into F6
for as long as it's on this H5 Square
it's not really doesn't have any forward
ideas so it's out of the ball game if
this King was in the corner
let's say and if the King was on h8 and
the Knight was on G8
I think many would be quick to say hey
that's an improving move I think you
should see this move as well as an
improving move because it's not doing
anything on the edge
this is a very important move to play
right now
anticipating
this queen side pressure
what does this move do exactly
well it's prepared to meet the capture
of the night with the recapture of the
night and this point remains strong
there's still the queen and Knight
defending B6
black does not appreciate this idea to
capture the Knight
and plays in this position G6 a new
square for the king but yeah the bishop
is kicked to a square it wanted to go to
in comes now
Bishop takes Knight this position is
officially collapsing for black there is
now a serious problem happening on the
queen side a serious problem with B6
this last capture
is doing what exactly
it's removing two
Defenders
from B6 Queen has to recapture this is
now unprotected
now just a word of caution an important
note here is
if you're going to or you should have a
good reason to give up your good Bishop
for a night white certainly has a good
reason
he is now laser focused on B6
it's a weak square a pawn is on it and
it's unprotected
now comes Queen B3 how do you defend B6
this guy
way out here in right field not a
contributor at all
how do you defend it
if you go here you're running into a pin
along the C file there's Knight takes
Pawn if you go back home well white
would simply add another attacker and
this guy has to move
so and then new square is weakened on C5
this ends up happening in the game B5 is
played straight away
okay from here Knight to E5 do you see
what just happened also with this last
move it started out where first C6 was a
hole then B6 was a hole
now after B5 C5 as a whole A5 as a whole
as well but no piece is really going to
get to that A5 Square 3. holes are
created on this queen side
it's a complete wreck now for black this
bishop not the brightest piece in the
world
okay from here Knight E5
Queen D6 is the reply
and can you spot White's next move
feel free to pause the video
okay
how do we get to this C5 Square do we
make some fancy maneuver like this
we could do it much faster if we're
attentive to
some pin there's one pin the B Pawn is
pinned Knight A4 is playable
so
actually a little better than Queen to
D6 it was saying Queen E7 to keep this
defended this does stop Knight to A4
if so if this move was played
it likes this as an idea it's a longer
path
light would be okay with the Knight
exchange and white would enter a
superior minor piece ending
this bishop is terrible in all cases so
in this game though it's Queen to D6
Knight A4 is available
and then we have Rook a to E8 so this is
already decisive Advantage here for
white
so too many weaknesses
what do you do here what other options
are there instead of the move played in
the game if you take the Knight this
Falls this is gonna fall it's hit three
times defended once that's gonna fall
that's going to fall complete wreck this
queen side structure for black
in this game it's Rook a to E8 Knight C5
you really can't ask for better posts by
these Knights
Bishop C8 this guy is going to get a
workout these next several moves she's
going back and forth constantly has to
babysit the backward C6 Pawn
we repeat moves here
and it goes to D3 back to C5 and now
white finally goes forward with this
tactical shot and picks up a pawn
Knight takes A6 is there
what do you do here in the game Bishop
goes to B7 defending this
if you take the knight in comes Rook
takes C6 that's how white gets the piece
back
so in this game Bishop B7
Knight C5
and from here Knight to D3
this is the target the very first
weakness that was created
in Black's camp
after move eight by black with B6
here we go doubling up the Rooks on the
C file
this guy is just a spectator throughout
it all and now
A4
what do you do there's still this pin on
the B file
in comes F6 what other try is there
there isn't a try
another Pawn is soon going to fall if
you try to defend
the bee Pawn right now white will be
crashing through on C6 so
black says let me release some pressure
on C6
F6 is played this of course drops the
two point Pawn
but at least at this point I guess is
maintained for a bit
throughout this whole game I should note
that black doesn't step foot
on white side of the board this is the
only moment right here to make a capture
on F4 but that's it that's how under
control this game has been this position
has been for white
very very one-sided not even a shadow of
a threat by black
okay from here Bishop A6 a takes B
and from here Knight takes on D5 there
is still a pin present first it was on
the B file after this last capture
there's now a pin on the C file this
paves the way for Knight takes D5 a
second Pawn has been lost and look at
these guys all isolated
from here Queen E6
white breaks the pin on the Knight The
Queen Is Now defended
minor pieces are exchanged heavy piece
ending alone
how does this end right here after Queen
to D3
black resigns what do you do
you're down two ponds you have a
terrible structure and white is
threatening two different main twos
there's no way to defend this
if play did continue let's look at at
least one or two moves
like F5
here's a good way to follow up
take time out to produce a flight square
and then you're ready to go all in with
your major pieces to attack the king for
instance Rook takes B2
you could go with Rook C6
and flick in a Check and Go Queen A6
white dominates ranks seven rank six and
seven it's already reading a a
maintenance seven right about here
so there's simply no defense
Queen D3 final move to this smooth win
by Kappa out of the Queen's Gambit
declined
very instructive how that patient play
early on that tension between the C and
D Pawn that delay with the King Bishop
created that first weakness and then
further weaknesses were provoked on the
queen side and it eventually collapsed
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it it
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye